hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
and this is my market analysis day is
Sunday actually it's at Sunday April
23rd I got 22nd on there but it's been a
long time since I've made a video I've
just my life's been upside down for the
last few months and I'm trying to get
everything sorted out it's getting to
the point where everything is just about
sorted out and I sort of get back on a
regular schedule and hopefully get some
more videos out to you but I I really
want to get a video out to explain
things to you about the order flows
trader software you know some of the
differences between my software and
other software oh and more important I
want to show you charts right now I'll
show you how to read the order flow now
before I begin a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision future
train contain substantial risk and it's
not for every investor and investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing once financial security or
lifestyle only risk capital should be
used for training and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
training past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
so you know that said you know let's
take a look at some charts from you know
the last the last week there there's
some very interesting things in the
order flow and you know ninja trader now
has an order full package built into
their software but it's just just all it
is is just a footprint chart and
honestly you could get order flow
software out there for practically free
oh yeah I mean I know you get you can
join you know some forums and then
they've got a footprint chart on there
but honestly what's the point if you
don't know how to use it okay if you
don't know what you're looking at
there's no point you could have you know
tea leaves telling you what to do but if
you don't order and read the tea leaves
you're not gonna make any right
decisions and you know with with order
flow there's a lot of information out
there and if again you know if you don't
know what you're looking at then you'll
never be able to make heads or tails of
it you know everyone always says well
you know you gotta have spent ten
thousand dollars in front of the screen
to become an expert at it well you know
what I could sit in front of a piano for
ten thousand dollars and hopefully buy
that
end of $10,000 I can play the piano am I
going to be you know be able to give a
concert no but will I be able to play
some songs yeah probably and you know it
training is the same way and you know
I'm really amazed by the number of
traders out there I don't wanna call
them traders I'll call them retail
traders that I've met who risked their
hard-earned money without learning the
basic skills required to improve their
chances of succeeding at trading you
know it's like in order to drive a car
without crashing it you know play par
golf you know golf that you know not
just you know I can go guy I'm a
terrible golfer I'll go out there and
you know they'll take me six eight
strokes to to finish the hole right but
if you want to become good you know if
you want to be able to bowl games
consistently over 200 you know you gotta
take time you gotta take the time to
learn the rules study the books and you
know learn from professionals you know
people that have been doing it for a
long time you know will take the lessons
from experts who you know who are there
out there you know people are out there
that really just want to help you
improve your performance in in trading
and you know really I find that most
retail traders don't take advantage of
the educational opportunities out there
and instead they just jump in headfirst
into the deep end thinking oh you know I
could figure it out and I can make money
you know honestly when it comes to
trading you're trading against people
that have been trading for a lot longer
than you have so it's not as if you are
trading against you know people with
equal skill levels it's not like you go
to karate class and you compete against
people the same deltas you know you're
competing against the sharpest minds
young people out there I don't like to
use the term sharks but you know they're
there they just want to get the money
out of your pocket and put it into their
pocket that's what they do you know
that's how they earn their living that's
what I did for a long time you know when
I was trading that was my sole goal was
to take money from other people it's
like playing poker the only difference
is you're not sitting at a table and
you're not staring at the guy you're
taking the money from you know you're on
a computer you're trading against
anonymous people on the other end of you
know of the trades could be one person
it could be a fund it could be whoever
you know and and the traders goal is to
get the money from somebody else's
pocket and put it in their pockets so
you know that's let's take a look so
this is the order flows trader software
this is my software that runs on
ninjatrader seven NinjaTrader eight as
well this is ninja trader 8 I've really
I've made the transition to ninja trader
eight this year you know sort of kicking
and screaming and it's still you know I
still think it sucks a ninja trader
eight honestly I mean you know that
ninja trader guys if I get angry at me
for saying that but compared to some of
the other software that's available up
there you know the ninja trader is
playing catch up on a lot of things
honestly is it good is it stable yes
it's it's stable but honestly sometimes
you know when you know little things
that drive me nuts is like you know if
you have to reinstall ninja trader 8 you
know say you had to reinstall windows 10
you know and Windows 10 is not exactly
the most perfect software out there
either no no software is perfect
honestly but you know if you have to
reinstall windows 10 then you got to
reinstall a ninja trader it's gonna give
you you know new machine IDs and you guy
go through all the registration process
is over and stuff like that it's just
that you know it's a little things like
that that just drive people up the wall
but um so this is crude this is this is
a 1-minute chart what day is this is is
Friday ordered of trains in June refrain
68 17 so you know what what makes the
order flows traders it different is it
gives you a lot more information than
just a normal footprint chart all right
and you know you've got your Delta okay
but you have what they want are called
ratios and this is a big thing you know
this is a major part of my order flow
analysis and this is something that I've
developed that people have been ripping
off copying and putting it in their own
software and calling it order flow I'll
go this order flow I'll go that but what
it does is it tells you when there's
price support or price rejection and
it's important because you know again
this goes back to the education part
right it's I I provide a lot of
education when you get my software you
know you get a ton of additional
education you get the 15 hours of the
order flows trading course but you also
get you know access to the inner
circle as well now when you buy the
software and you know right now there's
56 videos on there and you know I teach
things about you know like how to read
the imbalances how to you know use the
ratios how to use the points of controls
but you know like like in this case here
you know I can see here you know we're
at a swing high I've got a ratio I like
it's a blue number right if it's black
it's just your normal order flow numbers
if it's blue it's telling me something
in this case it's telling me there's
price rejection up here so you know this
is 3:00 in the morning Chicago time okay
it's kind of quiet but it's starting to
pick up his finally starts to pick up
around 4:00 in the morning I know this
price rejection up in here based on the
order flow and I see selling the balance
is coming in here as well you know and
we got a swing high we got negative
Delta you know that's a great trade set
up right there and you know if you know
were you don't place your stop you know
you that's that's the other thing that
drives me nuts is you know traders come
in and sometimes they think well I don't
need to use stops you know I watch some
guy turned a hundred dollars into
$20,000 trading Forex he doesn't use
stop so I could do the same thing
trading futures no you can't you no
matter what you do you need to need some
form of money management risk management
you know never trade with I only put
this way number trade with money you
can't afford to lose sometimes people do
that but you know even if you do
everything right even if you follow all
the rules even if you're the best trader
in the world you can still lose on any
given trade so you know to be trading
naked without any form of of money
management risk management rather is
this is gonna put you in the poorhouse
so here you know the to me this was very
low risk trade you know it can be
getting short here at 68 30 it just
comes down and there's sort goes
sideways like I said you know it sold
off about 5 ticks not the greatest trade
again it's 3:00 in the morning but I
know early in the morning there's price
rejection up here it's the 68 34 just
sort of goes sideways but then you know
as we're going sideways I see signs in
the order flow here here I see blue
numbers these are ratios that I like to
see okay now why am i more interested in
these blue ratios underneath as opposed
to the blue ratios above well we just
sold off okay and after after they sold
off I mean it was a move okay there's
this
a smaller move but again it's 3:00 in
the morning so we're just sort of going
sideways and you know I'm seeing more
blue numbers as underneath and blue
numbers above so I'm sort of looking at
this market it's just sort of putting in
a base now what's interesting is now the
deltas are kind of small it's kind of
you know again it's the morning time but
you know if you were to put a gun to my
head say Mike take a trade what are you
gonna do buy or sell well I see this
base being put in here I see a lot of
negative Delta's but I see blue ratios
and that's telling me that there's forms
of price support in here this this is a
price support that's price support this
price rejection and negative ratios so
I'm starting negative deltas so yeah you
got the negative deltas why isn't the
market selling off I mean you gotta be
asking yourself that you know you've
seen all these these negative deltas in
here but the market is holding why do
you have negative deltas cuz you have
support you have support of buying
coming in here bidding in the markets
right that the sellers are selling into
it that's why you got the negative
deltas and the markets not selling off
because someone is there absorbing all
that selling that's coming in you know
there's buyers they're willing to bid
the market and support that market and
the markets not selling off so that's
telling me you have some very valuable
information then you come down in here
Oh price rejection hey maybe the selling
is starting to dry up in here because
again you know you're not seeing you
know strong selling volume any more
coming in at these bottoms of these bars
you know the sellers are they're running
out of bullets they're running out of
ammunition and once the seller's dry up
what's gonna happen to the market is
boom you're gonna get the bar like this
where just boom pops up ten cents in one
bar in one minute these are the types of
bars you know you like to get you know
when you're trading especially on a
one-minute chart you know these are the
types of bars you like especially when
the bars you know prior to it are
trading 3 4 tick range --is and I'm
gonna get a 10 cent range those are the
trades you like to get and if you use an
order flow you know it can tip you off
it can tip you off to those moves before
they happen
okay so again you know then we just sort
of go sideways you know the signs of
price rejection here price resistance
here but again just sort of going
sideways sideways sideways no real clues
then boom here you get this nice red
hair let's tell me the trapped Raiders
that's what this red arrow is the green
arrow would tell me there's trapped
Raiders on the buy side but again you
know this is a bar with with two price
levels I put more weight into this one I
love this type of bar you know point of
control right at the high
you got a bearish ratio 0.47 is a blue
number I know with this arrow I got
trapped Raiders up here and what happens
boom it starts on off again you know
even though you have the blue eye sorry
the green arrow here indicating trap
sellers here are trapped buyers
I'm not putting too much weight into it
just because you know this bar is is
it's a minute chart you know this is one
of the things he I deal with my trading
a one-minute chart is quiet times you
get no price activity and it's kind of
hard to make heads or tails out of it
but when you're getting bars with very
valuable information like this you know
to me this is what I call a low risk
trade you know where's your stop your
stop is just right above here so start
trading up into this area and you don't
see selling come back in you get out
you're not placing your stop 10 ticks
past this no you just stop is just right
up here above this high so they imagine
you're getting short at 68 40 your stops
up here at you know forty seven seven
ticks stop and you know it was trades
down from $40 way down to you know down
to 30 here pops up a little bit to your
entry price and just sort of goes
sideways you know for the rest of the
morning then you know I said you know
five o'clock woman starts picking up you
get this nice pop up here there any
signs in the order flow yeah right right
here again you know it's you getting the
blue numbers blue number blue number you
got a single print right here but again
it's sort of coming after this period
where it's kind of quiet but you know
would you be taking it yeah it's a it's
a trade it's a training opportunity
what's your risk you know you're getting
along in here it started this bar your
risk is just right below you know this
this level right here so
you know you're just risking you know
four or five ticks and look what you can
get out of it that's a terrific move
then it just sort of goes sideways
sideways sideways sideways sideways
anyway let's fast forward it here excuse
me coughing now this is this is
something that I want to talk about here
okay so coming into six o'clock okay I
mean you know six o'clock Chicago time
which is seven o'clock in New York time
things are mmm I'll say normal but you
know it's it's New York session it's
running on the New York session I mean
obviously the old floor hours would be
seven but you know around 7 o'clock New
York Times six o'clock things really
start to pick up this bar actually this
bar right here let's talk about this one
look at this bar okay you got a bearish
ratio here even earlier you had a
bearish ratio but this one one two three
four five six seven eight imbalances
that's important all right you got
stacked imbalance here you know some
sort of split up imbalances in here
you've got this thin print in here as
two and against this five two against
two here so it's not a lot traded here
three five three two five okay so
someone just came in and swept that book
basically pushed it down here so it's
gonna be interesting to watch what
happens on this next bar are we gonna
trade back up into it and fill this sort
of quote-unquote gap or not and we do we
creat raid back up we get up to this
level but then it just falls back down
you know so this information here all
these thin prints is very valuable
information and again it's only
information you're gonna get from an
order flow chart from a volume footprint
chart if you're not using a volume
footprint chart then you know you're
missing out on that information and
there's your juicy information there and
you know if you're willing to take that
risk you know by watching this bar here
I mean you know granted this is a
1-minute chart a 1-minute chart and
you're talking about move from sixty
eight 53 down to sixty eight thirty
three so twenty cent move in one minute
it's a big move but you can't be
watching what's happening next what's
following up are we rejecting these
prices or what and we are we
ejected those prices right here we trade
it back up into it we didn't close this
gap of thin prints and we just started
sign off so imagine you can be getting
short here 6840 you know this bar here
sixty eight forty this is sixty eight
forty right here so say you get this
short somewhere in here you know you
know you got a level to hide behind up
in here sixty eight fifty so you know
maybe you're risking 10 ticks this is
sixty eight fifty right here you know is
it worth it okay I mean it's granted you
know again know this is a bar deist a 20
tick move but you know based on the
analysis that you saw in here said hey
you know what we didn't close this gap
you still had aggressive selling coming
in here you don't have the buying come
back in here to move us back up into
this area we just were so it's a decent
short opportunity so imagine you getting
short there at sixty eight forty yeah
you get this nice bar here from trade
from sixty eight forty down to sixty
eight ten now which is a nice movement
you just sort of go sideways work your
way back up hanging around here go
sideways then start coming into the the
main session and again you see it
similar thing right here alright look at
these thin prints in here one two zero
three thirteen stacked imbalances right
in here I don't have the stack and
balance indicator turned on but you know
if you did whoops I'll just give you
show you how to use this software a
little bit if you turn it on this is
what it looks like hopefully it'll come
up loop upper go to settings I have it
turned off display imbalance clusters so
I'll just make it a little bit stronger
so it's easier to read hope that's not
gonna be too strong then click apply ok
give it a sec you know it's it'll come
up here in a second bear with it
you
okay so here you see it right here again
this this is a multiple stacked
imbalance one two three four levels
notice how it's holding we trade you
know come back up towards it don't even
get in there again that's a low risk
short I mean imagine getting short here
at OU eight what's how much of a
drawdown you take you know it took it to
twelve I think twelve or thirteen before
boom the selling came back in and pushed
it down again seeing more selling more
selling more selling she's under
pressure okay now you know this is
interesting here okay so yeah you hit
this this below here sixty-seven what is
that sixty-one star trailing imbalances
imbalances imbalances and he has stacked
imbalance there you get Delta okay your
Delta 149 325 then 157 now if you got
long here right I'm not saying that you
shouldn't get long here because you know
I like trains like this where you're
coming off the off the low yeah you're
selling off you hit a low very strong
negative Delta I'd be looking for some
sort of bounce I would like this bar
better if you know this bar made a
little but you got positive Delta that's
a good sign and then it got stronger
positive Delta multiple imbalances
multiple imbalances stacked imbalance
off the low basically you know three
bars off the low I don't like the Delta
is getting a little bit smaller although
one of the reasons why it's smaller is
is the volume is quite light in there
then we just sort of go sideways sell
off a little bit get another stack
imbalance coming in here going sideways
you know honestly this to me you know
these two I would have taken along here
I would have taken along here this one I
would have been stopped out on this one
you know worked better but you know this
one I got I would take I would take
honestly I would like see a stronger
Delta here but you know I know that you
know the bottom is a little bit lighter
Delta's decent honestly you know I do
like that you got you know opponent
controls higher then you know it's the
same as previous point control and
higher than the point of control a
little bit further you know he's going
to be losses right and you know the
thing is right
when people say you know traders
nowadays you know retail traders they
they like everything to be black and
white and you know nobody likes to take
a loss and you know I tell people you
know trade each day to break even and
you know your first goal of each day
should just be to do no worse than break
even you know you want to live to trade
in another day understanding once you
understand the day trading is day in day
out it's a grind it's gonna take
patience patience and more patience and
you're not gonna earn a fortune in a day
period you know it's what matters is how
you wind up at the end of the month that
counts you know if you gear yourself
mentally and position yourself
financially I guess you know with proper
risk management's on your bad days you
break even when the good days come along
and you basically seem to win on every
trade you take I mean you know we've all
had those days you know we've all had
days where you can't do anything right
you know it's like you go to open the
door the door handle breaks you know you
go to go open the car the car handle
breaks you know there's you know we all
have those days and we also have those
days where no matter what you do you
can't make a mistake you know it's like
one's the same you know you'll be
walking around lucky and not even know
it but you know and so on those good
days those really good days that come
along were you know every trade you take
you know your counts gonna get bigger
alright so if you could you know control
your losses minimize your losses that's
important right so trade you know each
day coming you know I have this
mentality of you know try and come and
each Tate you know to break even
you know don't don't think that every
day you're gonna hit a home run you know
a training is a grind you know it's it's
yeah I laugh when I see these movies
like what was that one came out a few
years ago Wall Street - and they're on
the trading floor at a firm that
supposed to be like Lehman Brothers and
they're all shouting buy me this buy me
that so that yeah treyton wants crazy
Influenster not like that a lot of these
trading floors it's like being on a
library honestly it's so freakin quiet
and you know it's there's not people
constantly shouting you know on the CM e
floor and CBOT floor yes that's how it
was but you know not off on off the
floors you know it's more of a cerebral
game and you know people tend to keep
the
sells worse on the you know on the open
outcry and the trading pits you know
that was really the hustle and bustle
and yelling and screaming and waving the
arms around but not on not in not in a
bank trading floor so again you know to
be a successful trader at the end of the
month you know you gotta be around at
the end of the month so you know if if
you're how to put it you know if you're
not breeki trying to you know minimize
your losses you're not gonna be around
at the end of the month and you know
losses do happen no trades don't work
out again you know I thought that this
trade here was a legitimate trade I you
know the Mises and all systems go type
of trade it didn't work out okay you
move on wait for the next train
opportunity you get it here a slightly
better entry price but again you know
you still got to be able to take it you
know I know some people be like why I
just took this loss I'm not gonna wait
I'm not gonna take the next trade
because you know I want to see a win
before I take the trade well you do that
you sort of you're sort of trading your
trading method rather than trading in
the market and that's that's a mistake
that a lot of people make you know you
have to have confidence in your trading
abilities that when you do have a loss
that you have understand that you know
losses happen and you have to be able to
you know move on to the next trade you
know it's it's like with you know
basketball all right I mean good
basketball players you know they take
the shots and if they miss it they don't
get down on themselves they go on you
know get the ball back and they take
another shot you know that's what it's
about you got to be in the position so
that when the opportunity comes you know
you're going to take advantage of it and
it's not luck you know but it's it's
it's about being positioned you know
mentally and emotionally mentally
emotionally is the same thing but being
positioned positioning yourself so that
when the opportunity is there you can
take advantage of it so you know you
take this trade you take the loss period
you move on you take the next trade now
the next trade you're getting in here at
72 73 you know and well it goes all the
way up to 90 93
you know those that's what you got to do
right you got to move on from the trades
that that you know sting you to the next
trade because you know what it's gonna
be the next trade that's gonna come in
for you so now here this is interesting
now again you know this is similar to I
mean this trade here that didn't work
out okay notice this point of the
stacking balance it's it's an off the
low okay
I would like it'll you know I'll say I
like it more if it was on the low but
you know you got you can only train what
the market gives you you know it's not
you know not everything is textbook
examples but then you know look what
happens you get up here to a swing high
I got a bearish ratio I got a single
print
I got stacked imbalance again now that
this time is it's a stack solid
imbalance right so we just rallied about
30 ticks
I got a swing I got some selling coming
in here okay I can get short and what
are you doing I mean you get short here
94 is it a great trade no I mean it
trades down to about 90 you get another
stacks on a balance in here it just sort
of spins around spins its wheels
eventually it comes off you know from
the 94 area down into the you know the
84 area but it took a long time honestly
you know after you get this next stacked
and balanced you sort of run into these
bullish ratios 52 52 37 and the market
doesn't go anywhere you have this other
stacked imbalance in here this is the
one that you would have taken but you
just sort of spinning your wheels and
again you know this is this is another
thing that a lot of traders don't
understand is you know if you're not
getting paid on a trade you see you're
getting short here 67 95 so one minute
chart 721 730 still have breakeven 740
still around breakeven you get out
there's nobody's saying you got to stay
in this trade until it stops you out or
it goes to your take profit again you
know it's about minimizing your risk you
know the longer you're in the market you
know the greater the chance that you're
gonna have of taking a loss period I
mean yeah you can't win but you could
also have a loss so okay so then we
start coming into the eight o'clock time
and you know here's a stacked imbalance
you know but this mark is missed
going nowhere so I'd like to take
stacked imbalances you know at after if
it's a selling imbalance I'd like to
take it after move up if it's a buying
imbalance after a move lower not one
we've just been trading at the same
level for the last 15 minutes
you know 742 up to 750 for and as you
can see it goes nowhere goes nowhere you
know traders a lot of reasons
traders don't succeed is they don't take
trading their trading ideas in context
of the market they so I got stacks on a
balance I got to take it period no you
know you look to the left
what's been the market what's the market
been doing well you just been trading
there for the last 10 minutes 12 minutes
well it hasn't gone anywhere for the
last 10 minutes you know eventually
it'll go somewhere but you know it's not
gonna be the strongest signal then what
do you get right after it you get a bar
with multiple minor balances okay so as
you can see the market is just mixed
okay know what else they don't want to
talk about here it's really quick some
other stuff there's something bear with
me here I'm not trying to cherry-pick
but I just wanna sell you some good
examples of some decent trading
opportunities those one I got can't
remember what market was in I mean I can
go through all this but you know this
video would be ten hours long
okay so like this here so you have the
swing low you know you know way back in
here okay down here I mean even earlier
67-72 all right we start rallying rally
and rallying 72 get all the way up here
72 all the way at 68 32 and you guys
stacked buying and balance again this
will I talk about taking things in
context we just rallied 50 cents and you
got a stack behind the balance can the
market go higher yes it can but what's
the potential on the trade you know is
it gonna being give you a decent profit
I mean yeah exit it continue it can
continue keep going
or you know it can just go sideways so
you know or that could be the high that
could be your blow off the retail I'll
give you one that just missed this move
coming inside no crew just rallied 50
cents I got to get in and get in okay
then what nothing right if you have the
stack behind in balance what you would
expect to see is continuation right you
don't see the continuation coming
instead you just see a market hanging
around dad buying in balance that's not
a good sign that this buying in balance
is gonna work you know in this case when
the market was kind of generous to you
that had you gotten along off the stack
buying in balance you could get out at a
small loss because you know after the
stack buying in balance if after the
next three bars four bars it's just
hanging around not going anywhere that's
not a good sign and if anything is
assigned to get out of the trade now
this one here this one I love again you
know this is something you know this is
why I created the border flows trader
software and again you know this this is
something that is a very valuable piece
of information that you can get only
from the order flow and it tells you
when traders are trapped not everyone I
don't like the term trap traders because
it I think it insinuates something
that's not necessarily true so in this
case you know when people talk about
traders being trapped they'll say oh you
know yeah 40 Lots 82 lots 167 you got
these traders you know whatever that is
it's about 300 contracts 280 and they'll
say oh you know these guys you know
they're stuck okay well there's enough
volume for them to get out you know on
the way back up over the next couple
bars but instead what it's telling me
you know is tell me that there's no more
interest in here you know you sort of
have this like I said like I was talking
about earlier with that stack and
balance out that swing high where you
know you need the follow-through buying
right for the market to go higher here
you need the follow-through selling you
got selling imbalances in here why isn't
this market selling off why is because
you have some strong bidders coming in
here to support this market you don't
look at this area just look at this the
volume here 200 157 115 you know 90
135 160 782 you know I know that there's
strong support in here just on the bid
side okay I got a bullish ratio I got
point of control right on the bottom I
got the green arrow again I'm not
someone says like greet red light green
light systems but you know this is I had
to have some way that was gonna mark it
on the chart for me and easy to see
format that's telling me you know that
these people that are selling into this
low selling in the whole ours are stuck
right that there's strong support here
and what happens is you just sort of
linger around linger around and then
boom it finally pops up so you know
imagine you're getting along in here 68
28 again it's just sort of hanging
around here but then it pops all the way
up you know all the way up to 47 you
know 40 plus 45 but you know that was
something where you know the order flow
is telling you something okay now here's
another thing that's it's another setup
that I talked about with order flow this
is a three in a row one two three okay
and it's just three ratios in a row and
these are three bearish ratios that tell
me there's price resistance here so it's
a racial balance low so what that means
is it's a number between I'll show you
here if on the settings right and again
you know this is what separates my
software from all the other software is
you know we have these indicators I just
showed you the one with the trap traders
but this other one here or is it here
racial bonds high ratio of bounds low if
you set in a 28 it'll be blue if you set
it at point six nine so what it's
looking at is a number from 28 and above
for a racial balance high which
indicates price rejection ratio bounds
low indicates price support or
resistance and it's a number between 0.7
basically and zero can't be negative so
if I see a number above 28 I know that
there's price rejection if I see a
number below Oh point seven zero point
seven then I know that there's price
support or price resistance and when I
starts drinking that when you start
stringing them together in the same
direction as the market is moving down
or moving up in this case it's moving
down it's telling me that there is
resistance selling is telling me
there's there's sellers up in here
people offering the market capping the
market you got one two three in a row
you retrace back up
well this bar here opened up traded you
know within one take of that point of
control and then sold off you know
tomatoes are those that you know that
the easy trades
there's nothing easy and trading but you
know when you start putting these things
together in the order flow it just
really reveals the market reveals itself
in the direction that it wants to go now
here's a stagnant balance again you know
do I like this one it's sort of in this
area even though the market didn't go up
again I'll take it with a grain of salt
because it's coming in in an area where
we had just been trading for the last 15
minutes you know III don't find those to
be very high percentage trades honestly
so now that's not one that I would
normally take now again here's another
three in a row one two three in this
case you got ratio bombs low price
rejection ratio bonds high and a racial
balance low 1 2 3 and you know you get
long in here 6830 a quick you know 15 20
s you know 15 cent move from 6830 all
the way up to 68 45 i mean it went up to
68 50 I believe but again you know
that's that's the beauty of using order
flow and you know that's one of the
reasons why I created these tools you
know the ratios you know here you got
the red arrow telling you a potential
short notice how let's tell me that this
is an area where there's price
resistance this come back up because
these trade some good volume it did tick
through there before finally selling off
again you know multiple imbalances
that's why there's this that's what this
purple box is you know price rejection
up in here you know sign of earlier
price rejection earlier in this bar as
well market sold off and then you sort
of coming into the closed for the day
there all right so really quick this is
the bond market from Friday's for range
chart I like for range on the bonds so
here the market is just sort of going
sideways boom boom boom boom I'll notice
bullish ratio bearish ratio various
ratio a bullish ratio going sideways has
tax on them not stacks on balance got
multiple imbalances
4:29 69 to 14 then you get a bearish
ratio here single print single print
single print bearish ratio bearish ratio
bearish ratio one two three this is I
just showed you in the crude oil now
this is what I call the three in a row
look for a pullback sometimes you get to
pull back sometimes you don't in this
case you do you get the pullback between
these two pointed controls you get short
in here's where you get short is around
this point of control of the third bar
and again why are you doing it because
you know the ratios you know again I'm
not concerned with the number it's not
like you know 864 is any is greater than
64 it's a ratio song concerned about is
this is blue or not basically and you
know if you're getting short here you
know 160 through 140 318 you get a nice
move down to you know 10 you know even
down 208 but you know honestly you know
down in here I'm seeing the bullish
ratio coming in there now that's where
you'd be looking to get out somewhere in
here so you know from 18 down to you
know twelve six six six sticks in the
bonds you know and a lot of people will
be happy just to take that once a day
every day yeah then on the way back up
you know this is a nice thing I talked
about this type of bar these bars right
here in the inner circle this is a nice
buying opportunity right here but again
you know to get access to that you get
the software again it's it's all about
education and knowing what to look for
so you know hopefully you found this
video useful again I'm gonna try and get
more videos up now that you know my life
is sort of back on an even keel honestly
I got the guys that NinjaTrader on on my
back about a lot of stuff but my life's
really been upside down for the last
basically since you know this since the
whole year but you know things are
getting back down to normal and I'm
finding time to do stuff so thanks
everyone and have a great day bye bye